hello and welcome to this video playing
el jugador jugador supplier i think and
if i'm not mistaken from my tournaments
are played in Spain so let's see how
hope I'm little bit quicker at this time
we don't know what it is I'm really slow
at the mode yeah good old age 3 line
against the King Kings Indian Makka golf
my score is still pretty good with that
I think even though I sometimes feel I'm
spoiling lots of positions yeah had
almost the same position in a recent
game I mean in recent blitz game not
over the board it was some Queen f3
business like a queen e 8 it wasn't
exactly the same position but similar is
taking a long time but surprise I mean
that line is currently basically the
main line against the Kings Indian and
I'm surprised that he takes a long while
ok Tim she wants to go night g8
yeah ok so what to do here between the
three
I wonder some Queen a 3g three always
liked like the Queen them go nigh g8 of
course now not of course but that that
looks like the plan 9 ft sound doesn't
necessarily have to be ridiculous oh ok
now if he takes f5 I go Bishop e3 it was
my idea at least I mean she takes this
one okay it's a little bit surprising I
mean black should try to get some kind
of play okay okay just 25
hmm ok Jeremy I don't like that position
for black but this is almost always the
case and this in this opening line so
what am I doing here castles only I
wonder if you should play Knight age 5
to do something it doesn't seem to be in
a hurry to do it ok what now
how to play a night h5 maybe this to
prepare h5
yeah I know is going for that I'm keen I
can take and go butch if I for example
that check is very irritating okay I
have to take this is this is mandatory
and now should f6 is also coming
interesting and 93 @ for this is
something that irritates quite a lot
okay let's get out of the check first
yeah I wonder push-up f6 okay I go up g
five then you were probably bishop f6
play Bishop f6 so maybe just this
just keep that covered
ok so do i do a trade on g8 or not like
to improve my pieces here night d 2 nite
I would like to improve they currently
don't see how
not sure God smooth yeah I really didn't
have a clear way to improve couldn't go
up Jedrek Jedrek g1 as it takes on g 16
h form
I cannot he cannot take off course but
yeah I don't see a move I have to have
to play something though no I why could
I go here I should go to h1 at least 12
nite f 1 93 okay i know he allows me
that surprising check check so okay
bishop Karunanidhi is not a great idea i
guess okay let's see if i can regroup
now why are you three may be iced
goodnight be three though i had to move
a 3 hmm Jim and I knew that wow that was
a debatable decision
I can take we didn't do that you could
take their little screen d 393 chat
night but seems here he didn't see it
okay so check check
check oh that check I didn't seem nah
check
check check check check check no yes the
check no mine got check check what
forfeits I even forfeited on time what a
joke anyway ah I was up on the clock
here at the end almost anyway tough very
tough yeah this was a game that was a
very tough position to play him so Kings
it to wait for Bishop f6 jam that's very
difficult to play very difficult to play
my age for porn is weak and yeah I
wonder i really wonder what I what went
wrong I mean it wasn't bad it wasn't bad
but the Boucherie of six is just just a
very strange move that I should punish
somehow but i didn't manage may be here
i made a mistake by taking okay I'm the
ending point out this and white almost
winds um I am threatening age 6 m
that's a terrible position yeah that
mean Bishop Bishop f6 is just a pretty
awful move and so it shouldn't work it's
just far too slow so this was the point
I took that probably right quite quickly
yeah well the problem is f4 is a threat
and you are very rarely giving up this
Bishop in this kind of position but here
it makes it makes some sense to do as
black is not activating this pitch
Bishop ever and now he he almost has to
play that takes him and this is just
terrible that that's not a position that
black can play it's almost lost yeah the
engine is also on 1.5 and then someone
yeah so this is what I have to do hmm no
it's bad time match but I took that
immediately I also thought that I should
be better here but this is not not that
great that night h5 still keeps black in
the game and here keeps blacking the
game is the wrong phrase black is okay
yeah of course let's at age form move as
that is for porn is kinda high oops is
weak and I couldn't really figure it out
okay the computer wants to do with this
probably just play for this position but
i thought this 96 then it takes here
yeah this is it's just a very tough
position very unclear check check it's
just very unclear yeah he could have
taken f3 i blundered that
he played this instead you could have
taken yet because I cannot grab yes
checkmate cuz of the made you played
this so ever i know i'm ok again I think
you know it's still very tricky to play
check yeah yeah yeah i should get
checked made it but Queen f1 estimating
check now this is made checkmate so will
this so sorry check this check mmm Joe
didn't do it just early can make me a
couple of times but check carrot we have
to change this and the edges chat jen
has to make the draw now this end game
is despair for black bits of course it's
12 against six and even though I kind of
caught up at least look to me large and
I'm up on the clock even but it didn't
seem to be maybe some lag issues at the
end I lost sunshine which surprised me
yeah whatever ok thanks for watching